what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and things are kind of looking up for
Jonathan Majors lately in his case of
his alleged assault on March 25th
Jonathan Majors was arrested when the
police were called by him and they found
his at the time girlfriend injured they
arrested him and brought him down to the
New York City Chinatown Precinct he is
now being tried with several cases of
assault however Jonathan majors and his
team from the very beginning have stated
that he is innocent and actually the
victim in this situation and they have
provided many many pieces of evidence to
prove that he is in fact innocent in
this situation and that does include
video footage and eyewitness testimonies
and people who are willing to testify in
court about what they saw which is as
they State Jonathan Majors not
assaulting his now ex-girlfriend and
throughout this Jonathan Majors
unfortunately lost some deals his
management company dropped him his PR
Company dropped him he is lost out on a
project already and everybody has their
eyes right now on Marvel level Studios
wondering if Marvel Studios is going to
let go or fire Jonathan Majors from
playing Kang the Conqueror in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now people are
worried about this because as I
mentioned he's already been dropped from
some projects already and his management
company and his BR company and Marvel
Studios slash Disney for a long time
have not put his name or his picture
really on anything promotional for
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania in fact
they have delayed putting out Marvel
studios's Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania assembled piece which they
do for each project it's a making up but
Marvel Studios has delayed this
indefinitely and the reason they delayed
this is because they are essentially
waiting to see what happens in the trial
of Jonathan Majors but we do have some
good news today in terms of what Marvel
Studios is thinking and the timing
coincidentally is very good last week
Jonathan majors and his team went to
court for the very first time now
nothing happened it was basically just
the opening he just showed up didn't say
much and the judge pretty much said hey
we're meeting on this date this is when
the trial begins however something very
interesting happened Jonathan Major's
lawyer Priya Chaudhary stated to the
public that she thought the case
wouldn't even make it to court she
thought that this whole thing was going
to be dropped and the reason that she
thought all of this was because of the
evidence that they have presented to the
court and to the judge and this evidence
is what they called substantial enough
to irrefutably prove that Jonathan
Majors was innocent that's what they
said and we mentioned some of this
evidence before it includes video
footage it includes the professional
driver of the car who was driving them
when the alleged fight took place him
stating that the alleged victim was
actually the one hitting majors and
major got out of the car to try and
leave to avoid the fight it also has
Street video footage of Jonathan Majors
getting out of the car and the alleged
victim trying to pull him back into the
car it also shows the victim at a
nightclub just moments after the alleged
fight and assault on her took place
showing that she was not not actually
hurt at all in the footage because of
all the evidence that they showed they
thought that this case was going to be
dismissed and Jonathan Majors was simply
going to be innocent however they are
now going to court but what's
interesting is Marvel Studios and Disney
did decide to name drop Jonathan Majors
for the upcoming Loki season 2 credits
and they kind of gave him a little bit
of a Prestige title in an official
release by Disney for Disney plus as
Loki season 2 that is coming soon a
press release that was released
yesterday that can't physically be shown
publicly but States this for the cast
Tom Hiddleston Sophia dimartino gugu
umbatha ra unmi musaku Eugene Cordero
Raphael Casal Tara Strong Kate Dickey
Liz Carr Neil Ellis with Jonathan Majors
kihoi Kwan and Owen Wilson it's very
interesting that they put with Jonathan
Majors because as the direct.com States
who originally reported on this using
with before listing cast members usually
indicates that the actor is of great
prominence and also May feature a
limited role compared to the rest of the
actors but this is great news
considering everything that has been
going on lately and especially
considering that Disney has indefinitely
delayed Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania's assembled special now
again this was an official release from
Disney and it's really interesting that
this just came out because last week is
when Jonathan Majors presented all of
his evidence and as I stated when he
presented this him and his lawyer
basically thought that they were going
to Simply throw the case out and state
that Jonathan Majors was innocent they
had enough evidence to decide right
there but perhaps Jonathan majors and
his team showed all of this evidence to
Marvel Studios and Disney as well now
this is just speculation on my part this
is nothing official just want to clarify
that I'm just stating that it is pretty
coincidental and hopefully this does
mean a good good thing hopefully it is a
good sign hopefully Marvel Studios has
simply been waiting for the Court's
decision on the trial of Jonathan Majors
to make a decision themselves on whether
or not to keep Jonathan Majors as there
came the Conqueror now Loki's season 2
has already shot and according to a
report from thecosmiccircus.com Jonathan
Majors is scheduled to appear in three
episodes and we already know from the
post-credits scene of Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania that a variant of King
the Conqueror Victor timely is going to
pop up in the show we've already seen
him in those post credits and like I
said they've already shot all of Loki
season 2. now they have done some
reshoots and there was a rumor from Alex
P over at the cosmic circus that stated
at the end of Loki season 2 will show us
the fate of Jonathan majors and what I
believe is happening is that Marvel
Studios went and did reshoots to write
out Jonathan Majors I am not saying
they've already wrote him out but they
are preparing in case that has to be
done if Jonathan Majors is found guilty
Marvel Studios and Disney will replace
Jonathan Majors as king the Conqueror so
they are simply preparing for that they
are preparing for everything hopefully
it ends up not happening hopefully he is
innocent I do hope he did not assault
this woman and that turns out to be the
case that he did not assault her then I
do believe that they should keep him as
king the Conqueror because he's done a
great job so far in that case they would
stick to what they have originally
filmed for the ending of Loki season 2
this would most likely include a pretty
big setup for other variants of king or
another story for the main King in whom
we don't really know which variant that
is right now but give us a setup for
that King in the future because the Kang
Dynasty is not too far away and then
Secret Wars is a year after that but if
this official release from Disney is any
indicator at all of where they are
standing right now with Jonathan Majors
then this is a good sign especially by
adding with Jonathan majors and
especially considering they've kind of
really avoided trying to throw his name
out there so the fact that NFL official
press release had his name on there is a
great sign also something great to note
is that it still states that the
premiere is on October 6th of 2023 so it
has not been delayed yet and it does
offer a little tiny synopsis about Loki
season 2 which reads Loki season 2 picks
up in the aftermath of the shocking
season finale when Loki finds himself in
a battle for the soul of the time
variance Authority along with Mobius
Hunter B15 and a team of new and
returning characters Loki navigates an
ever expanding and increasingly
dangerous Multiverse in search of Sylvie
judge rinslayer Miss minutes and the
truth of what it means to possess Free
Will and glorious purpose and if you
remember in Loki season 1 Loki basically
stated that Free Will essentially
doesn't exist with the TVA being in
control and watch over everything so it
sounds like it's gonna get pretty deep
which the first one did as well and Loki
season one that is is my favorite Disney
Plus show and I know a lot of people's
favorites as well so let's hope that
season two is fantastic and let's hope
that if Jonathan Majors is found
innocent that he does remain as king the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but go ahead and let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below and of course don't forget to
subscribe and leave a comment below so
you can enter our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
the winner gets to pick one item and we
pick a winner at the end of each month
and in case you missed it we have
announced a winner for June and that
winner is Jason Murdock
9254 but the giveaway continues this
month so be sure to subscribe and leave
a comment down below you can also find
us on patreon you can check out our
website and Discord server as well and
you can check us out on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof